[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in chris sims pro football
talk co-host with mike florio
uh how about your saddest song what's
the saddest song in chris sims life
oh gosh this is a great conversation it
was actually really funny just to listen
to you and you know the guys there
certainly i mean you sound like you're
the teacher in front of the class now
fritzy tell me what happy song means to
you uh all right so
so i would go with
uh i would go with sad song you know a
lot the great gatsby right lana del rey
i mean this is totally off the top of my
head like will you still love me i want
to say it's that song right she's kind
of talking about what you love me when i
get older that's kind of a sad song that
i like
that would be that one you got to have
you say
when you say happy song i mean first off
pharrell and happy does pop to my head
right away it was kind of a happy song
but like what about like some bob marley
like three little birds you know every
time i hear that i always perch up you
know i like me some bob marley good
message
three little birds perch on my doorstep
how could you not like that song come on
yeah but that's usually when you're
returning from the dispensary when
you're listening to bob marley no doubt
and i'm encompassed in a cloud of smoke
and i go damn this is a great song
all righty if i would have said
yesterday at 11 a.m eastern
aaron rodgers and russell wilson will be
in the news
and uh the broncos are getting one of
the two you would have said who
i would have said aaron rodgers i would
have thought that was the the guy at
least you know the leader in the
clubhouse for that and i do believe he
was i believe he was plan a you know
they can spin it however they want i
mean it wasn't a coincidence yesterday
that aaron rodgers goes back to green
bay then a few hours later or an hour
later they signed russell wilson i don't
think that was a coincidence but yes
that would have been the move i would
have expected to have uh of heard
yesterday i think if you had to you know
ask me one of the two
if i look at we love to get grades on
these things but i'm just looking at the
let's look at what denver's doing now
and what seattle is doing now
let me start with seattle when you you
don't trade hall of fame quarterbacks
who were still considered to be in their
prime they did it uh is this a rebuild
for seattle
i i think a little bit i do you know
first off can you have a little bit of a
rebuild
yeah not really i mean not really they
have some pieces in place where you go
hey listen there's dk metcalf there's
tyler lockett there's jamal adams
you know there's there's uh the the
jordan brooks the linebacker they got
they got a few pieces to build around so
i don't look at it as like oh my gosh
this is a total tear down rebuild but
you're right there's no such thing as a
little bit of a rebuild you look at
their team
they got issues everywhere offensive
line nothing special running back
there's nothing there we talked about
the receivers okay tight end there's
nothing there no marquee defense
alignment bobby wagner's gone i
mentioned jordan brooks corners most of
america has no idea who plays corner for
seattle so i look at from that
standpoint and go it makes sense for
them this is how the seattle seahawks
started under the john schneider pete
carroll you know regime was them
building through the draft and some
quality value-free agents and i think
also dan what they got to look at is you
know a little bit of reading the room
where
they're a year away in my opinion with
russell wilson as we know who was
telling people for the last two years
that he wants to go somewhere where it's
all about him and be in a different spot
that they lose some leverage if they go
into next year and now this comes up
where it's russell in the last year of
his contract and everything that goes
around that to where i think they
realize they had a strike now why the
iron was hot
i look at denver and i do think they're
on the cusp
i don't think they're as close as what
people think just in my opinion i got a
rookie coach i'm not thrilled with the
offensive line
um
i know we love to look at that receiving
core and say man they're good i
jerry judy still has to prove to me that
he's he belongs in there with the fellow
alabama wide receivers um
i like the running backs
defensively they don't have a pass
rusher secondary's good
and you're playing in the afc west where
no doubt they're
what the third third best team in the
west are they better than the raiders
right now because they got russ
it's it's debatable i think yes as it
just as purely on the roster i would go
i like the broncos roster more than the
raiders yeah uh but yeah it's it's an
uphill climb and i think your questions
are you know they're real there's a lot
of what we would you know potential with
the broncos you know jerry judy he
certainly looks like he's a real good
receiver as unfortunate last year he had
that bad high ankle sprain cortland
sutton i do think is a star at the
receiver position but he was just coming
off a torn acl we saw tim patrick he's
really good kj hamler he's got three
rockets up his butt you know but was
hurt last year too so i think there's a
lot to look at there and go oh wow you
said it the offensive line's not great
but it turned the corner last year to go
oh it's pretty damn good and they can
open up some holes
now yes they gotta they gotta round out
i think your point there with the front
seven bradley chubb's got to be a force
again and they need another player or
two to be a difference maker up there
but they are close they really are and
in a lot of ways i look at it almost a
blessing in disguise that for denver and
nathaniel hackett that it's russell
wilson over aaron rodgers i really do i
know aaron rodgers may be playing better
football right now but i think you're
very
the reality is you're in danger if you
have aaron rodgers on the broncos and
two years from now you might be go he
might be i might retire and now you're
back right here with wait who's gonna be
our franchise wait so if you were denver
you're john elway
you would want russell wilson instead of
aaron rodgers if both were available
i think for the long term play the long
term if i was really looking at it like
hey i want to build something here not
just like try to make it happen in the
next two or three years i want to build
something where in the next six eight
years we're like one of the top teams in
the afc i think russell wilson's the guy
there and then now yes you bring him in
i know he doesn't know the offense like
rogers would know so yeah you lose that
but he's got a little base in the west
coast offense started his career in
seattle with that but also i just look
at it we just mentioned all those young
receivers you know you can kind of mold
them together and kind of grow as a
football team with a guy that you know
is going to be there for a long time let
alone there's some young talent on the
defensive side of the ball to where i
think you got a nucleus now of really
something to jump start the future for
the denver broncos where yeah rogers we
know it could be fickle and you could be
all over the place on a year-to-year
basis chris sims pro football talk live
co-host
uh how much pressure's on aaron rodgers
by staying in green bay as opposed to if
he had gone someplace else
well i don't think it changes a whole
lot i think there would have been more
pressure on him if he went somewhere
else and i think that's part of the
reason he probably stayed he probably
looked at it and said wait this is a
pretty good football team we got here
and
i'm the king i mean he's the king
there's no doubt about it that's the way
green bay runs their organization they
let brett favre be the king forever and
then they just said here here's the
throne aaron now you're the king and i
think that was probably that's probably
part of the reason he stayed too let
alone the football aspect of probably
looking at it going wait do i really
want to go somewhere get comfortable
with a whole new regime have the whole
locker room get used to me no he seems
like he's a little quirky from the
outside looking in i don't think you
would disagree that you know
having things he knows and the people he
knows around him i think are very
important to aaron rodgers yeah i i kept
logic would say why would you leave if
they're going to pay you right they're
they're really
you know agreeing to act everything
you're asking they acquiesce exactly to
you they stood up for you with the
immunization controversy there no they
had your back you lose nathaniel hackett
to denver but they bring in tom clements
your old quarterbacks coach they brought
back randall cobb for you feels like
they everything aaron asked for
they gave him and and then you got that
division
your schedule next year is not that
tough exactly afc east nfc east and you
throw in the nfc north
pennsylvan 13 wins 14 wins agreed
agreed you're right you know and now
field advantage out of the west i mean
you're right yeah they're they're you're
right they're in the cream of the crop
of the nfc and no doubt green bay
you know played the situation right to
your point too dan to where they they
made sure the public and everybody knew
hey we're doing everything to keep aaron
rodgers here they put all the pressure
on him to make the decision you know
rightly so and they you know now they're
going to pay him and everything there
but uh i'm i'm not shocked that rogers
didn't leave i was kind of rooting for
him to leave just for fun things to talk
about but not really surprised that he
stayed i guess the panthers are willing
to deal christian mccaffrey for a future
number one and uh and a player with a
low cap number here
man i got i got i don't know about that
though you know i mean you're you're
himming and haunting right just because
you're going wait you're going to trade
for him
oh i don't want him dollars no no no no
no it's expensive injury right prone
mileage and it's that position no no
exactly i never want a running back
i love derek henry
uh and i and i love jonathan taylor it's
when you get into those second contracts
at that position zeke elliott like i
don't want that
no of course agreed agreed and derek
henry's his own animal to your point
whereas you know first off tennessee put
the squeeze on him they didn't get
killed by his contract he's making what
five less million a year than mccaffrey
and you know he's also a guy where wear
and tear i don't think matters as much
because he's a giant and greek god of a
man yeah but i'm with you with what
you're saying with christian mccaffrey
that that is scary to me i if i'm a team
out there i'm certainly not trading
first round pick for a guy that has
played what ten games the last two years
you know after we paid him and is not a
naturally big man to begin with and did
have a lot of carries you know early in
his career and even at stamford that
would be a little scary for me too i
also wondered it was strange once i
heard the aaron rodgers news the first
person i thought of was jordan love
because
you know he's he's in the on-deck circle
he's not going to get to the plate and
then there are people saying well would
you trade jordan love well if i'm green
bay
at that price
no
no i gotta back up like why why am i
gonna give somebody jordan love
and i'm not here to be fair to jordan
love i'm trying to win if i got a
quarterback
knows the system maybe he can you know
work and we might work him in a little
bit more right maybe there's load
management with aaron rodgers the next
four i don't know but yeah right we
don't even know how the contracts
negotiated with rogers too it might give
him the ability to walk away after
another year or two and to your point
you know
i can't go through this again i can't i
know i can't i'm so sick of talking
about it too i i have had my limit i
love aaron rodgers as a player but damn
i'm talking about it i can't even lie i
really am well how about tom brady is
tom brady gonna join your boy kyle
shanahan in san francisco
i i'm saying it's 50 50. you know and i
know everybody thinks i know and have
inside knowledge you have never had a
conversation with your good buddy kyle
shanahan about tom brady are you gonna
lie to my face
no i will never lie to your face the
first time around when it was between
you know tampa and new england and san
francisco yes i had conversations with
my buddy about tom brady then yes i did
now this time around no i have not i
promise you i wouldn't lie to your face
i wouldn't i'm this is just connecting
dots first off you know i know brady
to miami was being talked about it was a
real thing sean payton possibly packaged
deal there so i don't think brady has
closed the door completely yet i do
think it's weird that um he was in san
francisco last week and kyle shanahan
wasn't at the combine all right that's
just weird i just died that's weird i
don't know and now they've hired brian
griese to be the quarterbacks coach and
i know you could say well it's for trey
lance he could also say it's her tom
brady and so again i i'm i'm with you
i'm not closing that door a month and a
half ago and said no he's done but
there's just too much around it right
now and some of his comments make me
believe that yeah it's not totally shut
yet
you share a tattoo with kyle shanahan
you don't even share a tattoo with your
wife do you
i do i well no i you know i do have a
tattoo of my wife's initials on here i
can't have a tattoo of my idiot college
friend's initials on me and not have my
family all right so they're on there too
now my wife didn't return the favor
she
she returned the favor dan let me tell
you this this is what she did this is
this is typical my wife all right for my
birthday she decides to get my name
tattooed on her ring finger and goes to
like the most expensive tattoo artist in
new york city
and she needs to go up to follow up to
retrace it a few times so it's like she
never does it so she paid like you know
like a thousand dollars for the name
christopher to be written on her on her
ring finger for like three or four weeks
and then it started to disappear that's
what i got back not you know that's not
real love i don't know what that is uh
before i let you go paulie has a bet
this is the over under quarterback first
quarterback selected at 13 and a half
paulie has the under a quarterback will
be selected in the first 13 picks
oh
it's it's a good spot there i mean
that's a good over under i'm going to go
with the under i mean we're saying under
you mean both for before 13. we're
saying 11 yeah i'm gonna go with the
under two okay i don't think it'll be
much before that but i think when you
get to nine and ten
teams will get antsy and somebody's
gonna make a move to go get the
quarterback then regardless of kind of
how they're viewed or valued as
first-rounders and you haven't chopped
up the quarterbacks yet have you
not yet i'm early stages i got a little
look of all of them i got a little feel
for you know the big the big name guys
that we're going to be talking about
definitely got some thoughts but haven't
done my real
deep dive evaluation which i'd love to
share share with you once i once i get
there are you a hand elitist because you
have big hands are you do you look down
upon kenny pickett
i i you know hands are a thing there's
no doubt is it foolproof 100
no it's not you know we're seeing
quarterbacks with smaller hands in the
nfl be really successful right now they
quarterbacks are more willing to grip
the ball differently than they have when
and when we grew up or in the 80s or 90s
you know there's a lot of different
variations of how quarterbacks grip the
football now as compared to then i think
that does it and with all the people
that i would be concerned with with
small hands the difference is with
pickett which i don't like that he wears
but he does wear a glove which you know
will help him out certainly but will do
i question how great of a natural
thrower you are if you have to wear a
glove to throw spirals and control the
ball certainly and that'll be a big
thing for me as i continue to evaluate
him oh it's great to talk to you bud
thanks for joining us chris thanks guys
be good
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host nbc nfl and college football
analyst